[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العنف
بوتين يتعهد بزياده انتاج السلاح النوعي
والقوات الامريكيه وروسيا تكثان البحثه في
البحر الاسود للعثور على الطائرات المحط
مه الاسواق الاوروبيه تمنى بخسائر قويه
وستتواصل حاله الهلع بعد تعثر عدد من
البنوك الامريكيه
وتعليق امر اعتقال عمران خان حتى صباح
الخميس بعد اشتباكات بين انصاره والشرطه
الباكستانيه
تظاهرات الفرنسيه ضد مشروعي نظام اصلاح
نظام التقاعد تتواصل
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه ما
تزال المعارك على اشدها لحسم السيطره على
باخمد فقد اعلنت مجموعه تحقيق تقدم جديد
في المنطقه الصناعيه التي تشهد قتالا
عنيفا مع تحصن القوات الاوكرانيه داخلها
وقد ذكرت فاجنر في بيان لها ان قواتها
تمكنت من السيطره على بلده
رغم نقص امدادات الذخيره والسلاح
واشارت الى اقتراب تطويق مدينه باخمت
بالكامل حيث نشرت صوره تشير الى سيطرتها
على خمس مدن محيطه بالمدينه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اعلن ان
بلاده تعمل بنشاط على زياده قدرتها
الانتاجيه للاسلحه الجديده واكد بوتين على
اهميه زياده انتاج السلاح في الوقت الحالي
ومستقبل مشيرا الى ضروره اشراف المدعين
العامين على تحديث مؤسسات الصناعه
الدفاعيه بما في ذلك زياده القدرات لانتاج
اسلحه اضافي
وفي تطورات الطائره الامريكيه المسيره
التي تحطمت بالامس اكد مدير الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الروسيه
ان الولايات المتحده تقوم بعمليات استطلاع
النشطه في منطقه البحر الاسود باستخدام
وسائل التكنولوجيه مختلفه وقال ناريشكين
ان الامريكيين يستخدمون بنشاط كبير جميع
الوسائل خصوصا الاستطلاع البصري
والاستطلاع اللاسلكي وقال سكرتيرو مجلس
الامن الروسي ان موسكو تحاول ايضا العثور
على حطام المسيره الامريكيه في مياه البحر
الاسود
في مقابل ذلك اكد الكرملين عدم وجود
اتصالات روسيه امريكيه رفيعه المستوى بعد
حادثه المسيره فوق البحر الاسود
واشار المتحدث باسم رئاسه الروسيه الى ان
روسيا مستعده
للانخراط في اي حوار بنا
المسيره الامريكيه كانت قد تحطمت بعد
صدامها بمقاتله روسيه فوق البحر الاسود
وبحسب الجيش الامريكي حاول الطائرتان
روسيتان اعتراض الطائره المسيره الامريكيه
مع ايقاف تشغيل اجهزه الارسال والاستقبال
الخاصه بها
الحادث وقع في حوالي الساعه السابعه
بتوقيت وسط اوروبا واستمر ما بين ثلاثين
الى اربعين دقيقه حسب الجيش الامريكي
وقد تحطمت الطائره المسيره بعد مناوره
حاده مع فقدانها تماما وقد نفت روسيا حدوث
اي تلامس مع طائره روسيه ما تسبب في سقوط
المسيره
ولعده مرات قبل الاصطدام القت مقاتلتان
روسيتان من طراز سخوي 27 الوقود نحو
الطائره المسيره بطريقه متهوره وغير سليمه
بيئيا ومهنيا وفق الجيش الامريكي ومن ثم
صدمت احدى المقاتلتين الروسيتين مروحه هذه
المسيره وهو مضطر القوات الامريكيه الى
اسقاطها في المياه الدوليه
من احدث المسيرات الامريكيه تمتلك مواصفات
تكنولوجيه عاليه
يعتمد عليها الجيش الامريكي في العمليات
العسكريه
سرعتها تصل الى 370 كيلو مترا في الساعه
قادره على التحليق لمده تصل الى اكثر من
30 ساعه تصنف بالطائره متعدده المهام
القدره على الرصد والمراقبه ومهاجمه اهداف
على الارض يمكن تسليحها بصواريخ هيل فاير
وكذلك بقنابل موجهه بالليزر نفذت ام كيو 9
مهمه في العراق وافغانستان وسوريا ودول
اخرى وفق تقارير استخدمت في اغتيال قاسم
سليماني وفي اغتيال زعيم تنظيم القاعده
ايمن الظواهري صحيفه واشنطن بوست تشغيل
الدرون ام كيو 9 يتم عن بعد بواسطه فريقين
في نحو 20 قاعده منتشره في 17 ولايه
امريكيه
لمزيد من المتابع انضم اليه من واشنطن
ريتشار وهو مدير برنامج التحليل السياسي
والعسكري في معهد سيد ريتشارد بك هل تعتقد
ان واشنطن ستسكت عن هذه الحادثه ام انها
سترد عاجلا اماجلا
كانت لدينا استجابه نسبيه الى الان كانت
هنالك ملاحظات ناقده جدا من قبل الجيش
الامريكي حول
الجيش الروسي وقالوا يتصرف بشكل غير مهني
الى اخره
وهنالك ايضا جهود الامريكيه لاستعاده
السيطره على المسيره قبل ان يحصل عليها
الروس ولكننا نعرف ان هنالك سلسله من مثل
هذه الحوادث مثلا عندما اسقط الايرانيون
سياره اخرى فوق المياه الدوليه الرئيس
ترامب حينها تحدى مستشاريه
وقرر قصف او ضربه ايران او مطالب منه
مهاجمه ايران وقال لا احد قتله ورئيس
بايدن يبدو لديه نفس التوجه امريكا
بالتاكيد يجب ان تكون حذرا
اذا
الاستجابه كانت اعدائيه جدا فقد تنبه
هؤلاء في مجلس الشيوخ الذين يرغبون
بايقاف المشاركه الامريكيه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه بسبب تكلفه ومخاطر النزاع مع
روسيا وغيرها فربما
اعلانات كثيره وبيانات كثيره تنتقد
سلوكيات الروسيه ولا شيء سيتجاوز ذلك سيد
لان ما جرى هو شيء طبيعي يعني طائره تجسس
امريكيه على السواحل الروسيه وجب اسقاطها
بشكل او باخر ويستشهدون بالقول يعني لو
كان هنالك طائره روسيه تتجسس على سواحل
سان فرانسيسكو لكانت القوات الامريكيه
اسقطتها سريعا فلا يحق لواشنطون الاعتراض
ما رايك
ربما هم محقون شهدنا الامريكيين يسقطون
المنطاد الصيني فوق الولايات المتحده ولكن
الفارقه هنا هو ان امريكا تدعي بان هذه
المسايره كانت تعمل فوق مياه دوليه وليس
فوق المجال الجوي او في المجال الجوي
الروسي ولذلك كانت لديها حريه التحرك او
المرور
ولذلك ما كان يجب ان يكون هناك اي تدخل اب
بهذا الشكل
شكرا جزيلا لك اعزائي المشاهدين ننتقل
مباشره الى موسكو ولقاء الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد مع الرئيس الروسي فلاتي بوتين
في اول زياره رسميه للرئيس السوري بعد
الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا
لنستمع اذا كانت الترجمه الترجمه جاهزه
لنستمع الى ما يقال في هذا
الاجتماعيه
لا يسمى العلاقات دبلوماسيه بين البلديه
اما جدول اعمال هذا فاقتراح مني ان نفصلها
الى جزئين الجزء الاول بمشاركه الزملاء من
مختلف الوزارات والهيئات
وبعد ذلك الجزء الثاني المتماثله في مادبه
الغداء ونحن نتبادل لاراء وجها لوجه
فرصه للمناقشه المفصله لكافه المواضيع
التي تهم الطرفين
والصعيد جدا برؤيتكم فخامه الرئيس اهلا
وسهلا شكرا لكم سياده الرئيس
في موسكو ونلتقي لكي نناقش الكثير من
الملفات الهامه المطروحه امام دولتين
قد تتطلب منا ان نلتقي ونضع تصورات مشتركه
للمرحله القادمه
للحكومه الروسيه ممثله الطوارئ على
المساعدات الكبيره التي قدمت خلال زلزال
الذي اصاب سوريا الشهر الماضي ان شاء الله
ياخذ شهور
وطبعا لوزاره الدفاع والجيش الروسي الذي
ساهم مساهمه مباشره في انقاذ المصابين في
هذا الزلزال
والذي كان له تاثير كبير في التخفيف عن
المصابين وفي التخفيف من اثار الزلزال على
المواطنين سوريا
[موسيقى]
واود ان اقول امتنان الشعب السوري لكم
وليال الحكومه الروسيه للمواقف الثابته
تجاه الحرب في سوريا
هذه المواقف المنطلقه من وحده اراضي
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه وسياده دولتها
[موسيقى]
في حاله حرب
ولكن
[موسيقى]
اريد ان
استغل هذه الزياره الاولى لي بعد بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا
الحرب ضد النازيه القديمه
واقول قديما جديده لان هذه النازيه دعمتها
دعمها الغرب قبل الحرب العالميه الثانيه
واحتضن قادتها بعد الحرب والان هو يستمر
في دعمه كما كان سابقا اياك
موقفنا لا ينطلق اليوم من الصداقه القويه
بيننا
ولا من الوفاء لمواقف سوريا تجاهنا
من حاجه العالم اليوم اعاده التوازن له
والا سيذهب العالم اتجاه الانفجار والنمر
وانا مرتاح جدا لنتائج اللقاء بين
المسؤولين السوريين والروس في اللجنه
المشتركه التي حصل خلال ايام الماضيه
والذي كان من افضل الاجتماعات التي تمت
خمار خلال السنوات الماضيه
التي توصل اليها هذه المره ست
ستمهد لمرحله جديده من التعاون الاقتصادي
فيها افكار وليس مجرد بيانات
لنهايه
يعني الزواج
مره اخرى اشكركم فيها
ان هذه زياره ستمهد لمرحله جديده في
العلاقات السوريه الروسيه في على كل
المستويات
نتائج حقيقيه يمكننا نبني عليها للمرحله
القادمه في العلاقات بين بلدينا والشعبين
نكتفي بهذا القدر اعزائي المشاهدين من
لقاء الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد مع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ابرز ما قاله
الرئيس الاسد نشكر
تشكر سوريا روسيا على مواقفها الثابته من
الحرب في سوريا
واضاف نؤيد موقف روسيا من الحرب في
اوكرانيا لانها تواجه النازيه القديمه
الجديده حسب تعبيره وان هذه الزياره ستؤسس
لمرحله جديده في العلاقات بين موسكو ودمشق
بالطبع هذه الزياره وهذا اللقاء ياتي في
اطار مساعي روسيه لاصلاح العلاقات كما بات
معروفا بين دمشق وانقره عشيه اجتماع رباعي
يجمع روسيا سوريا تركيا وايران فيما خص
الازمه في سوريا
في شان اخر منيت الاسواق الاوروبيه وعلى
راسها اسهم قطاع البنوك بخسائر حاده في
جلسه اليوم لتستمر حاله الهلع التي اصابت
الاسواق بعد تعثر ثلاثه بنوك امريكيه خلال
ايام قليله ونتيجه للتراجعات الحاده تم
ايقاف التداول لفتره وجيزه على اسهم اكبر
البنوك الاوروبيه في وقت تجاوزت فيه خسائر
بعض الاسهم نسبه 30%
وتستمر حاله من عدم اليقين في حجم تاثير
ازمه تعثر ثلاثه بنوك امريكيه على راسها
بنك اس في بي في كاليفورنيا وتداعياته على
النظام المالي العالمي فيما افتتحت
الاسواق الامريكيه على انخفاض يفوق 1%
للمؤشرات الرئيسيه
هذا وقد حث رئيس بنك سيليكون فالي بريدج
الذي انشاته السلطاته المصرفيه الامريكيه
حديثا ونقلت اليه كافه ودائع بنك سيليكون
فالي المتعثر حتى جميع العملاء على اعاده
اموالهم التي قاموا بسحبها واكد على ضروره
اعاده بناء قاعده الودائع لدعم البنك
المنهار
ياتي ذلك في الوقت الذي تشهد فيه البنوك
الكبيره بينها بنك اوف امريكا وجيبي
مورجان تدفقا كبيرا في الودائع يذكر ان
المؤسسه الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع
اكدت انها ستغطي جميع المذيعين في بنك
سيليكون فالي حتى سقف المئتين وخمسين الف
دولار امريكي
معي من عمان لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع الباحث الاقتصادي مازن ارشيد
استاذ مازن اهلا وسهلا بك هل نحن امام
ازمه ماليه عالميه جديده بدات بالتدحرج ام
لا لا يجوز تكبير الحجر المساله
تتعلق بعدد من البنوك الامريكيه ولن تتاثر
باقي دول العالم بما يجري
يعني هو قد يكون من السابق لاوانه الحديث
عن مقارنه الحقيقه ولو ان المقارنه غير
واقعيه حتى هذه اللحظه بين ازمه عام 2008
وايضا افلاس بنك كبير مثل
وقتها وايضا نتكلم عن بنوك حجم متوسط نوعا
ما في الولايات المتحده افلاسها مثل
سجنتشر وسلك وغيره لكن واضح بانه حتى خلال
تعاملات البورصه في اوروبا في الولايات
المتحده يتم يعني التركيز اكثر على البنوك
ذات يعني نسبه القروض الى الودائع لديها
متدنيه جدا يعني بنتكلم عن 35 بالمئه فما
دون ذلك لانه يعتبر يعني يعني من النسب
المتدنيه وطبعا بتكون الودائع حوالي ثلاثه
اضعاف القروض وبالتالي سوف يقوم تقوم
البنوك بدفع يعني
فائده بشكل اكبر مما سوف تتل من فوائد
نتيجه اقراضها للشركات والافراد بطبيعه
الحال واضح بانه التركيز في هذه الحاله
على هذه البنوك تحديدا ولو انه القطاع
المصرفي بشكل عام يعني متراجع بشكل كبير
ولكن هنالك بنوك بتتراجع فعليا يعني بشكل
ستين بالمئه
وحتى سبعين بالمئه خلال الثلاثه ايام
الماضيه وبالتالي واضح بانه لا تزال
التخوف والهلع موجودان رغم انه هنالك
تطمينات من الاداره الاداره الامريكيه
وتطمينات من الهيئه الاوراق الماليه
وغيرها من الامور استاذ مازن انت بتعرف
دائما مسطولها على يعني توصيفي بهذا الشكل
عندما تصاب امريكا بالانفلونزا تعطس جميع
دول العالم هل نحن امام سيناريو مشابه
لسيناريو بنك ام لا والا كيف نفسر هذا
الهبوط في جميع الاسواق او معظم الاسواق
العالميه بينها حتى الاسواق الخليجيه
لانه طبعا يعني احنا
ذكرنا نسبه يعني القروض الى الوداع ولكن
لماذا بعض البنوك حتى في منطقتنا العربيه
في اوروبا في اسيا وحتى في الولايات
المتحده خلال الثلاثه او الاربع سنوات
السابقه الحقيقه وقبل ارتفاع يعني معدل
التضخم العالمي في الولايات المتحده كانت
اسعار الفائده قريبه من الصفر مئوي وكان
هنالك يعني
الاستثمار من جميع الشركات الحقيقه في
العالم وحتى في الولايات المتحده باسهم
خزينه
الخزينه الامريكيه سواء كانت قصيره الاجل
ام طويله الاجل كانت يعني عائد ثابت بواقع
واحد ونصف بالمئه مع ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
الحقيقي وهذه المشكله عم بتواجهها المصارف
في العالم ارتفاع اسعار الفائده يعني
علاقتها عكسيه مع قيمه هذه السندات سندات
الخزينه كلما ارتفعت اسعار الفائده وهو
حدث بشكل متسارع جدا خلال
تراجعت قيم هذه السندات وبالتالي قيام هذه
البنوك ببيع هذه السندات من اجل توفير
المزيد من السيوله لديها ادى الى تحقيق
خسائر في ميزانيتها بطبيعه الحال وهو اللي
يعني هنالك تصيد لهذه البنوك في العالم
اللي اكثر انكشافا على شراء والاستثمار في
سندات الخزينه الامريكيه تحديدا من عمان
الباحث الاقتصادي مازن رشيد شكرا لك استاذ
مازن على هذه المشاركه
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
مخاوف امريكيه من تحول افغانستان شيئا
فشيئا الى ملاذ للجماعات المتطرفه
اهلا بكم من جديد انسحبت قوات الشرطه من
محيط منزل رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
بعد اشتباكات مع انصاره وفق قناه جيو ال
باكستانيه وبحسب الشرطه فقد تم ايقاف
عمليه الاعتقال بسبب مباراه كبيره للعبه
هذا وتجمع المئات من انصار خان امام منزله
بعد وصول فريق من الشرطه من اسلام اباد
لاعتقاله بناء على امر قضائي ووفق مصادر
طبيه اصيب 54 شرطيا وثمانيه مواطنين في
الاشتباكات الجاريه منذ الثلاثاء
رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق عمران
خان قال ان الحكومه تريده وراء القضبان
لمنعه من المشاركه في الانتخابات وقال
خالي وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان مذكره
الاعتقال الصادره ضده ليست بسبب خرقه لاي
قانون لكن الحكومه تريد حبسه حتى يتم منعه
من دخول الانتخابات المقرره في وقت لاحق
من هذا العام
[تصفيق]
اهلا وسهلا بك هل فعلا السلطات
الباكستانيه مصممه تماما على اعتقال عمران
خان ام لا كل ما يجري عبد الرحمن مجرد ضغط
سياسي على عمران خاليه وقف حملاته
الاعلاميه ضد الحكومه
نعم الحكومه الباكستانيه
نفت صلتها بالقضايا المرفوعه ضد عمران خان
ومذكرات التوقيف بحقه وزيره الاعلام
الباكستانيه مريم زيد اكدت بان القضايا
المرفوعه ضد عمران خان هي قضايا جنائيه
بحته ولا دخل للحكومه فيها وعلى عمران خان
الالتزام بما تمليه عليه المحاكم وما تمره
به
المحاكم وقضاتها
اود الاشاره هنا الى ان الاوضاع هنا في
مدينه لاهور بدات تعود الى الهدوء النسبي
بعد نحو 24 من المناوشات المتقطعه بين
قوات الامن وانصار رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان كان هناك قرار من قاضي في محكمه
لاهور العليا امر قوات الشرطه بوصف
تنفيذ الاجراءات المتعلقه بمذكره الاعتقال
الصادره بحق رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
عمران خان حتى صباح يوم غد الخميس ايضا
كان هناك التماس قدمه الفريق القانوني
لامران خان امام محكمه لاهور العليا وايضا
امام محكمه اسلام العليا هناك عده
التماسات لتوقيف العمل بمذكرات الاعتقال
بل والغائها وايضا الغاء بعض القضايا
المرفوعه بالضعف عمران خان يعتبر ان
القضايا المرفوعه ضده قضايا
ويؤكد انه لم يخالف القانون عبد الرحمن في
حال تم اعتقاله ما الذي قد يقوم به انصاره
والذي تخشاه الحكومه يعني اي ردود فعل
يمكن توقعها
الساعات المقبله او ربما يوم غد سوف يحسم
مساله اعتقال عمران خان من عدمه عمران خان
او الفريق القانوني العمران خان قدم
تعهدا لمحكمه السماوات العليا بانه سوف
يحضر جلسه يوم السبت المقبل ايضا قدم
التماسا لالغاء مذكره التوقيف لكن قاضي
محكمه العليا لم يقبل هذا الامتنا لكن
احاله مساله قبول تعهده بالمسؤول امام
المحكمه الجنائيه الى المحكمه الجنائيه
نفسها التي ستحدد ان كانت سوف تقبل
بالتعهد الذي قطعه عمران خان للمثول
امامها يوم السبت المقبل وعلى هذا ربما
يوم غد هو سيكون حاسما بما اذا سوف تواصل
الشرطه او
ستقوم باعتقار رئيس وزراء السابق ام سيكون
هناك راي مغاير لقاضي المحكمه الجنائيه
ربما بتوقيف مذكره الاعتقال بحقه لكن فيما
لو تم اعتقال عمران خان فهو قد حذر من انه
بات يفقد السيطره على انصاره وحذر من ان
ما تقوم ما قال انها ما تقوم به الحكومه
يجر البلاد الفوضى والهدف من ذلك هو
تاجيل موعد الانتخابات هنا في اقليم
البنجاب والذي من المقرر ان يكون بتاريخ
الثلاثين من ابريل المقبل من لاهور شرق
باكستان مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن المزيني
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الرحمن على هذه
المتابعه
قال الممثل الامريكي الخاص لافغانستان
توماس وست لقناه تولي نيوز الافغانيه ان
طالبان لم تلتزم بوعدها عدم استضافه
المتطرفين الذين يرغبون في الحاق الادب
دول اخرى وعدم السماح بالتدريب او التجنيد
كما اكد مسؤولون امريكيون بان الجماعات
المتطرفه المتمركزه في افغانستان خططت
ونفذت هجمات ضد باكستان وطاجكستان
واوزباكستان وان هناك اكثر من عشرين جماعه
مسلحه في افغانستان وحدها
ووفق خبراء تدير طالبان الان دوله ذات
حدود سهله للاختراق من سته جيران بلا جيش
نظامي وتعاني من عقوبات دوليه وهي غير
قادره على تلبيه توقعات الولايات المتحده
لمكافحه الارهاب الخبير بمجموعه الازمات
الدوليه جرام سميث قال ان مقاتلي حركه
طالبان باكستان يحتمون في افغانستان
ويهاجمون باكستان
طالبان من جهتها نفت ايواء الجماعات
المتطرفه داخل افغانستان مؤكده التزامها
بمنع التهديدات الامنيه للدول الاخرى
لكنها اقرت بفشلها في منع الهجمات
المتطرفه داخل افغانستان حيث قتل حاكم
طالبان في مقاطعه بلغ الشماليه في هجوم
انتحاري تبناه تنظيم داعش الاسبوع الماضي
وفي ديسمبر من عام 20 22 اعلن تنظيم داعش
مقتل مسؤولي سياسه المنطقه في مقاطعه
بتخشان الشماليه الشرقيه
منذ ثلاثه عقود والقلق ما زال يسود
الولايات المتحده بشان وجود مقاتلي
القاعده وقادتها بافغانستان
انخرطت الولايات المتحده في افغانستان بعد
هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر للبحث عن قاده
القاعده في اطول حرب خارجيه في تاريخ
امريكا في عام 2022 قتل زعيم القاعده اي
من الظواهري في كابول في غاره امريكيه
بطائره مسيره وهو امر رفضته طالبان بان
الظواهر قتل في كابول مسؤولون امريكيون
يقولون ان زعيم القاعده الجديد سيف العدل
وهو ضابط سابق في القوات الخاصه المصريه
يتواجد في ايران وسط نافيين من طهران
اجلت الدائره القضائيه جلسه التحقيق مع
حاكم مصر في لبنان الرياض سلامي الى غدا
الخميس بسبب التغيبه عن الحضور هذا وطالبت
وزاره العدل اللبنانيه باعتقال حاكم مصرف
لبنان الرياض سلامي وشقيقه ومساعدته وحجز
املاكهم بعد توجيه اتهامات لهم بالاختلاس
والاثراء غير المشروع وغسيل الاموال من
جهه اخرى وصف فريق الدفاع عن حاكم مصرف
لبنان استدعائه للمحاكمه امام قضاه
اوروبيين بانها انتهاك للسياده
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
الي من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي يوسف دياب
استاذ يوسف اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشره
الخامسه منذ الامس لم يكن احد ليتوقع الا
قله قليله ربما ان يمثل السيد رياض سلامي
حاكم مصرف لبنان امام القضاء اللبناني
لانه وكما يقال لبنانيا على الاقل هو محمي
لديه غطاء سياسي وهو خط احمر ما
نعم الى حد كبير هذه الاحتماليه او هذه
الفرضيه هي صحيحه بالتمام بالامس رياض
سلامه تبلغ رسميا موعد الجلسه التي كانت
مقرره قبل ظهر اليوم وكان اعطى وعدا بانه
سيحضر جلسه التحقيق اليوم فوجئ القضاه
الاوروبيون والقضات اللبنانيون بان سلامي
امتنع عن الحضور رغم انهم انتظروا في
القاعه المخصصه لاستجوابه لاكثر من ساعتين
ونصف الساعه ولا بيحضر بحسب المعلومات ان
رياض سلامي بررر تغيبها على الجلسه بانه
قدم مذكره توضيحيه كما تفضلت وقلت في
الخبر يفيد فيها بان حضور قضاه اوروبيين
الى لبنان
واخضاعه للاستجواب بشبهات تبييض الاموال
على الاراضي اللبنانيه يتعارض مع القانون
اللبناني ومع السياده اللبنانيه لكن سرعان
ما رده النيابه العامه الت ورفضت هذه
المذكره واعتبرت ان حضور القضاه
الاوروبيين ياتي استكمالا المهمه التي سبق
لهؤلاء القضاه ان اتوا من اجلها في شهر
يناير كانون الثاني الماضي واستجبوا
خلالها عدد كبير من المصرفيين والمسؤولين
في مصرف لبنان وبالتالي بات لزاما على
رياض سلامه ان يحضر الجلسه التي كانت
مقرره غدا التي اصبحت مقرره غدا الا اذا
كانت ثمه موانع سياسيه تفرض عليه عدم
الحضور الى الى هذا التحقيق طيب استاذ
يوسف
منذ الكلام عن احتماليه توقيف رياض سلامي
وشقيقه ومساعدته وهنالك انهيار مضطرد
ومريع في سعر صرف الليره هل هنالك ارتباط
عضوي بين هاتين المسالتين بمعنى للسيد
رياض سلامي وسائله من الضغط على الاسواق
الماليه اللبنانيه يعني اذا حدا بده
يعتقلني او اي قضاء بده يعتقلني فعلى
الليره السلام هل يمكن الربط بين
المسالتين
يعني قد يكون لهذه الفرضيه تاثير ولكن
تاثير محدود جدا يعني علينا ان نتذكر
دكتور طالب بان انهيار العمله الوطنيه بدا
في العام 2019 قبل ان يكون هناك حديث عن
ملاحقه رياض سلامي او قبل الكشف بسنتين عن
وجود ملفات ماليه لرياض سلامه انا اعتقد
ان الامر بالنسبه للانهيار العمله ربما
يكون لسلام الرياض
لظل رياض سلامي دور بالتلاعب بسعر الصرف
من حين الى اخر لكن الواقع ان الاقتصاد
اللبناني والماليه اللبنانيه منهاره الى
عد الى حد كبير
يعني شئنا ام ابينا مصرف لبنان بدا يفقد
ما تبقى من احتياط الزامي ولم يعد بمقدوره
اليوم ان يضخ الدولارات في السوق لاجم
يعني ارتفاع الدولار بشكل كبير انا اعتقد
اليوم ان الان
يسبق كل التطورات القضائيه التي نتحدث
عنها ولو كان الامر يعني قابل للمعالجه
باجراءات يقوم بها حاكم مصرف لبنان اعتقد
ان يعني الطبقه السياسيه التي تحتمل اليوم
برياض سلامه لكانت لجات الى الخيار انا
اعتقد ان المساله هي مساله انهيار شامل
على صعيد الدوله وبنيه الدوله بشكل كبير
من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي يوسف دياب شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
ايطاليا تسعى لانشاء بعثه اوروبيه في
افريقيا لمعالجه مشكله الهجره
اهلا بكم من جديد للمره الثامنه منذ كانون
الثاني يناير الماضي يتظاهر معارض اصلاح
نظام التقاعد الذي طرحه الرئيس الفرنسي من
المكرو وتامل النقابات ان تظهر الاحتجاجات
في جميع انحاء البلاد معارضه العمال
والموظفين الهائله لخطه رفع سن التقاعد من
62 الى 64 عاما في حين يحاول البرلمانيون
ايجاده تسويه بشان هذا النص الذي يثير
جدلا وتبدو الحكومه مصممه على تمريره مع
او بدون تصوير
لمزيد من المتابعه معي هنا في الاستوديو
مدير مكتب قناه العربيه في فرنسا حسين فيا
اهلا وسهلا بك طيب
لنفهم المشاهدين لماذا الحكومه الفرنسيه
مصره تماما على اقرار هذا القانون اي ان
تكن التداعيات حتى لو كانت هنالك خساره
سياسيه مدويه للرئيس ماكرون
في الواقع الحكومه والرئيس مترو يعتبران
انه لا يمكن مواجهه العجز في ميزانيه نظام
التقاعد هذا العجز الذي سيصل بحسب الحكومه
عام 2030 الى 20 مليار يورو لا يمكن
معالجه ذلك الا من خلال تمديد عمل
الفرنسيين سنتين اضافيتين اي رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما طبعا سند
التقاعد في المانيا مثلا هو اقل بقليل من
66 عاما في ايطاليا هو 67 عاما في فرنسا
هو حاليا 62 عاما في عهد الرئيس الاسبق
الراحل فرانسارون كان 60 عاما رفعه سركزي
الى 62 عاما وهو ماكرون يقول انه لا بد من
رفعه الى الاربعه والستين عاما يعني
بالنسبه الى
الحكومه
ما الفرق يعني بين 62
على الاقل على المستوى المالي في ميزانيه
الدوله وكيف يمكن اقناع العمال والنقابات
بهذا الشيء اولا يعتبرون طالب ان رفع او
ارتفاع معدل اعمار الفرنسيه خلال السنوات
الثلاثين الماضيه بفعل التقدم الطبي فرض
هذا العجز في ميزانيه نظام التقاعد وان
على الفرنسيين ان يمولوا هذا النظام
التقاعدي والا فانه لا يمكن الاستمرار
بهذا النظام قد يتعرض للانهيار المالي اذا
لا مفر من ذلك تقول الحكومه ثم تقول ايضا
انها قدمت تنازلات من بينها ان الرئيس
ماكرون كان يصير في البدايه على ان يرتفع
سن التقاعد بدءا من ايلول سبتمبر المقبل
بواقع اربعه اشهر كل عام ليصل الى 65 عاما
عام 2031 قدم تنازل فاعتبر انه يمكن
القبول من طرف الحكومه برفع سن يقعد بدءا
من سبتمبر بواقع ثلاثه اشهر كل عام بدلا
من اربعه اشهر وصولا الى الاربعه والستين
عاما عام 2030 هذا اول تنازل التنازل
الثاني من قبل الحكومه كما تقول الحكومه
نفسها ان الذين يتقاضون دخلا محدودا الا
الذين يتقاضون الحد الادنى للاجور لن يكون
عليهم العمل ثلاثه واربعين عاما كما هو
مطلوب من الاخرين بل انهم سيحصلون على
الراتب التقاعدي الكامل حتى لو لم يعملوا
ثلاثه واربعين عاما شو الحل كل طرف متمدرس
حول موقفه نحن سبعه اشهر او ثمانيه اشهر
هل من حلول هل من وسطات
نعم هناك لجنه برلمانيه مختلطه شكلت من
سبعه اعضاء في الجمعيه الوطنيه اي مجلس
النواب وسبعه اعضاء من مجلس الشيوخ بعد ان
فشل اعضاء مجلس النواب على فشلوا في تبني
هذا المشروع مشروع القانون تبناه طبعا
مجلس الشيوخ حيث الاكثريه يمينيه لكن حزب
ماكرون لا يتمتع بالغالبيه في الجمعيه
الوطنيه اي مجلس النواب لايجاد مخرج شكلت
لجنه برلمانيه مختلطه معظم اعضائها يؤيدون
رفع سن التقاعد اذا نجحوا في ذلك تكون
الازمه انتهت يوم غد يصار الى التصويت في
الجمعيه الوطنيه على مشروع قانون اصلاح
النظام التقاعد واذا لم تنجح اللجنه
البرلمانيه المختلطه لدى الحكومه سلاح
اخير ستلجا اليه اذا عجزت عن اعتماد حلول
اخرى وهو اعتماد الماده
49.3 من الدستور الذي يتيح لاي حكومه ان
تمرر مشروع قانون ما حتى فشل في الحصول
على غالبيه يربط البعض ما يجري في
الموازنات الاورو والاكلاف التي تدفعها
اوروبا في الحرب في اوكرانيا لدعم
اوكرانيا هل يمكن الربط ما يجري الان في
فرنسا مع هذا القانون بالاكلاف التي تدفعه
فرنسا لدعم اوكرانيا ام لا هناك وجهان
للاجابه على سؤالك الوجه الاول ان مشكله
اصلاح نظام التقاعد في فرنسا مشكله مزمنه
كانت سجلت تظاهرات ضخمه عام 95 في عهد
حكومه الانجيبي الذي كان اول رئيس وزراء
في الولايه الاولى
وحينها نزل ملايين الفرنسيين الى الشوارع
ولكن الوجه الاخر للمشكله ان ما حصل في
اوكرانيا هذه الحرب الواقعه في قلب اوروبا
ضغطت على ميزانيه الدوله الفرنسيه ما يفرض
اصلاح نظام التقاعد براي الحكومه والامور
اذا اما تتجه نحو تصعيد اي اعتماد الحكومه
على الماده 49.3 التي تتيح لها تمرير
مشروع قانون ما حتى لو لم توافق عليها
غالبيه البرلمانيين اذا حصل ذلك سيكون
هناك تصعيد كبير في الشارع تلوح النقبات
وتقول انه في حال عدم حصول موافقه
برلمانيه واعتماد الحكومه على هذا الخيار
الاخير سيكون الرد في الشارع قاسيا اشاره
اخيره لو سمحت لي باريس مدينه العطور
ونتيجه اضراب عمال النفايات الذي يستمر
حتى العشرين من هذا الشهر بدات تنبعث
رائحه كريهه من
6600 طن من القمامه في باريس وهذا امر غير
مسبوق في فرنسا مدير مكتب قناه العربيه في
باريس حسين في شكرا جزيلا
تامل ايطاليا ان توافق الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي في قمه مارس على انشاء
بعثه المجتمعيه في البلدان الافريقيه
الاكثر تضررا لحل مشكله الهجره المتزايده
هذا وقال نائب رئيس الوزراء الايطالي
ووزير الخارجيه سابقا انطونيو تاياني ان
زياده الاستقرار ومحاربه ازمه الغذاء
وتغير المناخ تعني تقليل عدد المهاجرين
غير الشرعي قضيه الهجره صعدت الى الواجهه
مره اخرى لا سيما بعد الماساه الاخيره
قباله سواحل منطقه كلابريا الجنوبيه
الايطاليه نتيجه لغرق سفينه في السادس
والعشرين من فبراير ما ادى الى مقتل حوالي
مهاجرا
نشط الخامس انتهت اطيبه التحيات والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]